[موسيقى]
مساؤكم واهلا بكم الى التاسعه هذا المساء
هذه عناوينها
بعد مسيرات تضرب موسكو للمره الثانيه
وتكسر حصانتها بوتين
في اي دور لها
[تصفيق]
اتهامات الدعم السريع البرهان ينفي اي صله
للاخواني بالحرب ويهددهم باستخدام القوه
المميته
[موسيقى]
صراع محتدم بين بكين وواشنطن لخطب ودي
افريقيا والعروس السمراء تستعرض ثرواتها
صفقه بايدن مكارسي حول سقف الدين تواجه
اختبارا عصيرا في غرفتي الكونجرس بعد
ساعات من الان
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء الطائرات
المسيره سلاح الحرب الاستراتيجي في
اوكرانيا بدا بمهام ثقيله لقصف القطاعات
واعاقه الامدادات وتطور ليصبح انتحاريا
ذاقت كييف مرارته طويلا وصرت ان تذوق
موسكو من ذات الكاس فجر اليوم الثلاثاء
استفاقت موسكو على هجوم بمصيرات تسبب
باضرار في ابنيه دون ان يسفر عن سقوط قتلى
الاضرار ليست الاهم في هذا الهجوم بل ان
وصول مسيراتك الى موسكو شكل صلب الخبر
اوكرانيا وكالعاده في هكذا هجوم نفت
مسؤوليتها وقالت انها تصدت لعشرات
المسيرات التي ارسلتها روسيا ادى لمقتل
شخص على الاقل
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى موسكو معنا من هناك مراسله
العربيه كاتيا كاتيا اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء بدايه كيف تطور المشهد
عقب هجوم المسيرات للمره الثانيه على
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
مرحبا نادين بالفعل هذه هي المره الثانيه
التي يتم استهداف فيها العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو
بسيارات طبعا هذا الاستهداف مختلف عن
سابقته بانه اصاب مدن عفوا ابنيه سكنيه
بالاضافه لذلك انه كان مكثف وضخف من من
حيث عدد المسيرات التي وصلت الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو هذا هو الاستهداف الثاني
بعد استهداف الكريم والذي علق عليه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اليوم بنفسها الذي
قال انه عمل ارهابي يقف وراءه النظام في
كييف طبعا هو بررر هذا التصرف من الجانب
الاوكراني لانه كرده فعل على
عمليه اجرتها روسيا يوم امس عمليه ناجحه
وكما وصفتها بانها قامت
بتدمير احد مقرات اتخاذ القرار في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي اوكرانيا قامت بالرد
على هذا
بارسال مسيرات الى العاصمه الرو كما حدث
الصباح صباح هذا اليوم نديم طب كاتيا ولو
ان الهجوم الاوكراني الاخير جاءك رده فعل
كما تقول موسكو لكن اليوم هل نتوقع ردا
روسيا على هجوم المسيرات
بالفعل نادين كما علقت الدفاع الروسيه
وعلى لسان وزير الدفاع
الروسيس الجيش الذي قال انه طبعا هذا
العمل الارهابي لن يبقى بدون رد وان موسكو
طبعا ستقوم بالرد كالمعتاد
لذلك سنتوقع ان يكون هناك طبعا تكثيف كما
اعتدنا على روسيا التكثيف للهجمات على على
اوكرانيا او على المواقع التي تستهدفها
القوات الروسيه خلال العمليه العسكريه كنا
قد شهدنا خلال الايام او الايام اليومين
السابقين هناك كان قصف عنيف من الجانب
الروسي لمناطق وصلت طبعا الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف وكانت طبعا ايضا كما
اعتبرت روسيا انها رد على كل ما قامت به
اوكرانيا اولا من عمليه
التغلل الى داخل الحدود الروسيه عبر مدينه
بيل غرود الحدوديه التي ايضا كانت قد
اتهمت روسيا ان هناك مجموعه تخريبيه قناه
تسللت الى الاراضي الروسيه بالاضافه الى
عمليات الاستهداف
التي نشهدها هنا وبالاخص المناطق الحدود
الحدوديه الروسيه المشتعله التي دائما
تستهدفها اوكرانيا بي مسيرات تستهدف طبعا
منشات بنيه تحتيه سواء كانت تابعه الى
مؤسسات العسكريه الروسيه او حتى المدنيه
ايضا هناك في المناطق الحدوديه ارجو ان
تبقي معنا يبدو ان محمد البابا اصبح جاهزا
معنا الان من محمد اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء هل تستعد كييف للتحذير
الروسي بالرد وبالاجراءات التي تراها
مناسبه
نعم بالفعل يعني بحسب ما يتداول عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وايضا ما ينشر من وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه والرئاسه الاوكرانيه
بالطلب الى المواطنين بالالتزام بالانذار
الجوي وعدم يعني التوجه الى الشوفات او
الى يعني المباني المرتفعه والذهاب فورا
عند اطلاق سفارات الانذار الى الملاجئ
وذلك تحسبا من هجوم او تقوم به القوات
الروسيه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه خلال
اليومين الماضيين كشفت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه او كسفت الجيش الروسي عمليته
واستهدافه للاراضي الاوكرانيه وخاصه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه يعني قبل امس كان هناك
هجوم بمختلف يعني الاسلحه في الصواريخ
والمسيره ثم ظهر امس كان هناك هجوم
للصواريخ وليله امس كان هناك هجوم
بالمسيره لذلك يعني الجانب الاوكراني يعني
تماما خطوره الموقف والتصعيد الروسي خلال
اليوم الماضيين ذلك هناك دعوات للمواطنين
خاصه عمده مدينه كييف اليوم يعني طلبه من
المواطنين في عدم الاستهتار واهمال
الانذار الجوي والتوجه فورا الى الملاجئ
خاصه يعني اليوم الضحيه التي سقطت في
منطقه يعني كانت تتواجد على شرطه منزلها
وعندها السقوط المسيره او حطام المسيره
على منزلها ادى الى وفاتها وهي كانت كانت
في التوابرك العليا لذلك هناك دعوات الان
من السلطات الى الجميع بالالتزام بشكل
فوري والزامي يعني سفارات الانذار والتوجه
الى المناشي فورا طيب محمد
خلال الاسابيع والاشهر الماضيه والدفاع
المستميت من كلا الجانبين عنها هل من وجهه
جبهه ميدانيه محدده اليوم تستعد القوات
الاوكرانيه والجانب الاوكراني للتوجه
اليها والتمسك بها
يعني بالامس كان هناك اجتماع لمجموعه او
المجلس الحربي كما يوصف باللغه العربيه مع
الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي وتم التداول وبحث
يعني موضوع الهجوم المضاد والخطوات
المقبله لوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه والقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ويعني بحسب ما اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني كانه اعطى موافقته
والضوء الاخضر لتنفيذ الخطب التي وضعتها
هيئه الاركان العامه يعني وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه والقوات المسلحه
تنفيذ الهجوم المضاد خلال يعني الايام
القليله المقبله او الساعات القليله
المقبله الان هناك حاله ترقب لمعرفه كيفيه
الهجوم المضاد الذي يعني كما اعلن ميخائيل
مديوليات قبل يومين هذا الهجوم سيكون عن
سلسله هجمات وليس هجوم كلاسيكي بالمعنى
العسكري بل سلسله هجمات ستكون بها القوات
الاوكرانيه على مختلف الجبهات التي هدفها
هدف هذه الهجمات تحرير الاراضي التي احت
لتها القوات الروسيه منذ بدايه الغاز
الروسي الاراضي الاوكرانيه حتى اليوم شكرا
جزيلا لكما من كيف محمد البابا ومن موسكو
كاتيا تومي
[موسيقى]
افاده السلطات بالجورود روسيه
انصفاوكرانيا جديدا طال قريه نوفايا دون
وقوع اصابات بين المدنيين كما طال القصف
الاوكراني قريه اخرى تدعى مروم للمره
الرابعه مع تحضيرات حكوميه لسكان قريه
كوزينكا بضروره الاختباء بسبب استمرار
القصف من قبل اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لم نطلق العنان لهذه الحرب في عام 2014
اختار نظام كيب معاداه روسيا واضطهاد
الروس في دومباس ونحن لا نستخدم هذه
الوسائل التي يستخدمها قاده نظام كييف وما
حدث اليوم تاكيد اخر على ذلك المنشات
المدنيه السلميه في موسكو تعرضت للاستهداف
وعلى العكس من ممارسات الجيش الاوكراني
تنفذ قواتنا ضربات دقيقه ضد منشات البنيه
التحتيه العسكريه ومنها مقر المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الذي تعرض للقصف قبل
يومين او ثلاثه ايام اختار نظام كييف
مسارا مختلفا مسار محاولات ترهيب روسيا
وتخويف المواطنين الروس وضرب المباني
السكنيه وهذه بالطبع علامه واضحه على نشاط
ارهابي
او مكانه تعرف بسله الفاكهه الاوكرانيه لم
تعد بالحلاوه والالوان نفسها فرائحه
التعذيب تنبعث من كل مكان هناك مدعون
اوكرانيون وجهوا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم
حرب لاربعه من افراد الحرس الوطني الروسي
وهو جهاز اسسه بوتين قبل سبع سنوات ويقطع
مباشره له بعض ضحايا ساعدوا بالتعرف على
المتهمين الاربعه من خلال صور لوحده الحرس
كما ساهمت معلومات استخباراتيه واعتراضات
هاتفيه بالتعرف عليهم احد عشر مركز احتجاز
تم اكتشافهم حتى اللحظه هذه المراكز مجهزه
بغرف تعذيب شهدت مئات الجرائم بما فيها
العنف الجنسي والاعدامات الوهميه وفق
شهادات ناجين الضحايا تعرضوا للضرب وحرم
بعضهم من الرعايه الصحيه فيما ابلغ 17
محتاجه عن تعرضهم للتعذيب الجنسي بالصدمات
الكهربائيه اسفرت عمليات التعذيب وفق
نيويورك تايمز عن مقتل ثلاثه اوكرانيين
بينهم امراه مضيفه ان هذه القضيه واحده من
اولى القضايا التي ظهرت بعد التحقيقات
الادعاء العام الاوكراني اكد مواصله
الاعمال الهادفه الى تحديد مواقع غرف
التعذيب والاحتجاز غير القانوني مبينا انه
يريد التعرف على جميع الضحايا
الواقعه جنوبي اوكرانيا سيطرت عليها روسيا
لنحو ثمانيه اشهر قبل استعادتها مجددا من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في نوفمبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
بخموت الفقده لاي قيمه استراتيجيه استماتت
كيفو موسكو للسيطره عليها لتنتهي العشره
الاشهر الاخيره بانتصار الجانب الروسي اذا
لكن دعونا نتحدث عن هذه المدينه الصغيره
الواقعه شرقي اوكرانيا كانت اثقلت كاهل
روسيا وتحولت ايضا عبئا وانتصار معنوي
ومكاسب دون مغزى فالمعارك الطويله
والمكلفه تركت جنودها اذا مرهقين ومحاصرين
مع فرصه ضئيله للتقدم كما تقول وولز ورغم
ان الدفاع عن ضخمه لفتره طويله كان كلف
اوكرانيا بشكل كبير لكن كيف لم تنتشر ايضا
في هذه المدينه ولم تنشر ايا من الاولياء
هذه الالويه التي نتحدث عنها التي كان
جربها ايضا الدنو الجنود وايضا جهزها
الحلفاء الغربيون استعدادا لاي هجوم في
هذه المنطقه اذا ما تحدثنا بالتحديد في
شرق اوكرانيا في وقت تساعد اوكرانيا لهجوم
اذا واسع النطاق سعيا لاستعاده ما يقرب من
خمس اراضيها من روسيا منطلقه من بخمت
بالتحديد اذا اذا ما تحدثنا ايضا عن جديد
الاستعدادات حيث ان روسيا تستعد لهجمات
مكثفه في هذه المناطق ولكن ايضا قوات
مستنزفه بشده في معارك ضخمت وايضا قسمات
متسعه داخل مؤسستها العسكريه علما بين
قوات انسحبت بالكامل من باخمت كما وعدم
مؤسسها ولكن ستكون هناك حاجه الى قوات
اخرى للاحتفاظ بها
[موسيقى]
فنلندا العضو الاحدث في حلف شمال الاطلسي
تدير وتستضيف احدث الاستفزازات للجاره
الروسيه فسلاح الجو الفنلندي اعلن عن بدء
عمليه تحدي القطب الشمالي والتي تستمر
اسبوعين واصفا اياها باكبر مناورات تنظم
حتى الان هذه المناورات تنظمها الدول
الاسكندنافيه كل سنتين منذ عشر سنوات وتضم
اربعه عشره دوله هذه المره 12 عضوا
بالنيتو بالاضافه للسويد وسويسرا
التدريبات واسعه النطاق تشمل نحو 150
طائره مقاتله من دول غربيه بينها الولايات
المتحده بريطانيا وفرنسا وستتمركز
الطائرات في شمال النرويج والسويد وفنلندا
وكذلك في قاعده بيركال تمبير الفنلنديه
تتزامى المناورات مع اجتماع لوزاره خارجيه
الحلف في اوسلو هذا الاسبوع وكذلك زياره
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى فنلندا بعد
يومين
[موسيقى]
وردا على التحرك الفنلندي استدعت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه سفيره فنلندا في موسكو
ابلغته بقرار تقليص الوجود القنصلي مع
بلاده في الخارجيه التونسيه ذكرت ان موسكو
قررت ايضا خلال هذه المرحله من تقليص
الوجود القنصلي المتبادل مع فنلندا لانه
لا يتوافق عن مع المستوى الحالي لعلاقات
الروسيه الفنلنديه
اكد حلف الشمال الاطلسي اليوم ارسال قوات
اضافيه الى كوسوفو وذلك عقب الشبكات مع
محتجين صرب في المنطقه فحلفوا شمال
الاطلسي اضافه ايضا في بيان له بانه اصدر
توجيهات بنشر قوات اضافيه وذلك ردا على
اضطرابات التي وقعت في الاونه الاخيره
واصابه سلا فردا من قوه الحلف
التاسع هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
الصين ترفع تحدي وترسل روادها الى محطتها
الفضائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى التاسع هذا المساء وفي
تفاصيلها ايضا سودانيا قال رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان ان
الجيش لم يستخدم ما وصفه بالقوه المميته
حتى الان في السودان وقال انه اذا اصرت
قوات دعم السريع فالجيش سيلجا لهذه القوه
اضاف البرهان الجيش يسيطر على جميع
المواقع العسكريه في السودان بشكل كامل
والقوات الرئيسيه لا تزال على الارض كما
نفع عبد الفتاح البرهان تصريحات قوات
الدعم السريع عن الحربه في السودان ضد
جماعه الاخوان واكد رئيس مجلس سياده
السوداني ان الجيش السوداني وافق على
الهدنه لايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين
[موسيقى]
منها ان الخدمات تمشي لاهلنا الناس
المساكين البنات المغتصبا وبيوتهم حرماتها
ومال النهب
بدون ذنب بدون ذنب وبدون سبب يقولوا الحرب
ضد الكيزان
الشعب السوداني
ين كلهم
ونحن في القياده نموت كلنا هنا
البرهان توعد باستخدام ما اسمها القوه
المميته والمفرطه في حال لم تتراجع قوى
تدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
اذا العدو من صاع وما استجاب حنضطر نستخدم
عجزت الهدن المتعاقبه عن وضع حدا المعارك
في السودان بين الجيش وقوه دعم السريع
وزاد الوضع خطوره دعوات لتسليح المدنيين
قد تودي بالبلاد الى اتوني حرب اهليه ذات
طابع اثنين مدينه الجنينه شهدت هذه الحرب
الاهليه فعلا وقد تمتد لتشمل باقي المناطق
في السودان فاكثر من 5000 قطعه سلاح تم
توزيعها على اسس اثنيه والقوات المسلحه
كانت وجهت دعوات المتكرره لتصليح
المواطنين احتقان الوضع دعا عبد الله
حمدوك رئيس الوزراء السابق للقول ان
السوداني يواجه خطر التفكك محذرا في كلمه
نشرها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مطلع
هذا الشهر من ان بلاده تواجه خطر كارثه
انسانيه بعد ان مزقت الحرب العاصمه
الخرطوم وشردت اهلها
اخاطبكم اليوم بصفه المواطن السوداني الذي
يشفق على بلاده واهلها اخاطبكم وبلادنا
تواجه خطر التفكك وقول ان الرصاصه حين
تنفلت من السلاح لن تميز بين المعتدي وغير
المعتدي والضحايا هم السودانيون يجب ان
يتوقف الرصاص فورا ويجب ان يحكم صوت العقل
فالخساره ستكون من نصيب الجميع ولا يوجد
منتصر على جثث شعبي
طبعا هذا الوضع الانساني المتردي في
السودان قد ياخذ البلاد الى ابعد من ذلك
فالصدمات الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه ظواهر
مناخيه قصوى كانت كفيله بعدم صحوه بعض
البلدان من غيبوبه الفقر والانزلاق اكثر
فاكثر الى مستنقع المجاعه ثمانيه عشره
بؤره ساخنه للجوع تضم 22 بلدا مع تنام
انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد حجما وشده وفق
الامم المتحده افغانستان نيجيريا الصومال
وايضا جنوب السودان واليمن لا تزال في
اعلى درجات التاهب فيما تم رفع مستوى
القلق في هايتي بوركينا فاسو ومالي وحتى
ايضا السودان الى اعلى مستوياته فالمنظمه
الدوليه حذرت من امتداد الازمه في السودان
متوقعه فرار اكثر من مليون شخص وتفشل جوع
الحاد بين نحو مليونين ونصف المليون شخص
داخل السودان في الاشهر المقبله اما اذا
ذهبنا الى
وباكستان وحتى سوريا فتعد ايضا من البؤر
الساخنه التي قد تثير قلقا شديدا ولائحه
اضيف اليها لبنان مؤخرا التقرير داعي الى
اتخاذ اجراءات انسانيه عاجله لمنع حدوث
مجاعه ووفيات في البؤره الساخنه مرجحا
تفاقم الخطر بحلول نوفمبر المقبل اما
المدير العام لمنظمه الاغذيه والزراعه
فاستبعد فعاليه مسارات العمل المعتاده
واكد الحاجه الى تدخلات زراعيه فوريه
حاسمه التوقيت لانقاذ الاشخاص من براثن
الجوع
[موسيقى]
تشهد ولايه الجزيره وسط السودان موجه نزوح
عاليه للمرضى من الخرطوم بسبب استمرار
الحرب فيها بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع فيما اشتكى بعض المرضى من ندره
انواع جديده من جرعات السرطان في الوقت
الذي تتوفر فيه بالسوق السوداء وباسعار
عاليه
الصوره من داخل ثاني اكبر مشافي العلاج
الكيميائي والاشعاعي لمرضى السرطان
بالسودان
اوجاع المرضى واهات الاجساد التي تملكها
المرض العضال ازدادت بعد الحرب والسبب نقص
الادويه والضغط على المستشفى بسبب نزوح
مرضى السرطان الى ولايه الجزيره واقع تسبب
في ندره بعض الادويه وزياده اسعار الجرعات
في السوق السوداء هكذا يقول البعض
ولدنا انعمك السلام
[موسيقى]
الواحده
مؤشرات الضغط على المستشفى بدت واضحه بسبب
خروج نحو 30 مستشفى بالخرطوم عن الخدمه
الامر الذي افرز تحديات صعبه في الامداد
الدوائي وبعض المعينات كاوعيه حفظ الدم
نزح اعداد كبيره جدا من المرضى في اتجاه
ولايه الجزيره في اتجاه مكه المعهد القومي
للسرطان
ممكن مستقبلين حتى الان احنا
1723 حاله حتى اليوم
حالات جديده
ليس ببعيد عن المستشفى تستقبل هذه
الاستراحه اعدادا كبيره من مرضى السرطان
الذين لا يملكون ماوى في هذه المدينه اذ
يتم العمل على توفير الايواء والغذاء
بمجهودات شعبيه ودعم نوعي بسيط الاستراحه
على ضيقها هي الاخرى تعاني من ضغط المرضى
عندنا من التشاد وعندنا من جنوب السودان
فداء ادى لتكدسهم وجود بالاستراحه يعني ما
بيقدروا يرجعوا اهلهم الا يطلقوا العلاج
وبرضو للاسف الشديد يعني تقطع مع العمليه
تحت العلاج انه العلاج ما متواصل او عدم
توفر العلاج فيه اوقات كثيره ادى لوجودهم
هنا داخل الاستراحه الصوره اشد قساوه مما
هو ظاهر على عدسه الكاميرا فقدرها هؤلاء
الذهاب باوجاعهم الى مكان امن وب بعيد عن
اصوات القذائف والرصاص لتلقي الجرعات على
ندرتها وي خوضون حربا لاستعاده العافيه
لاجسادهم وبلادهم كذلك التي تعاني من مرض
عضال يهدد بقاء الدوله بانسانها وهكذا
يقول البعض محمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ودمدني بولايه الجزيره
[موسيقى]
هل تحل الصين محل روسيا في اسيا الوسطى
سؤال بات يتردد في الاونه الاخيره خاصه مع
تحركات الصين في تلك المنطقه فرئيس الصيني
التقى بزعماء اسيا الوسطى يوم الخميس
الماضي وكعاده التنين الاسيوي تركزت معظم
المباحثات حول التجاره لكن الزعيم بكين
تحدث ايضا عن مساعده دول اسيا الوسطى على
تحسين انفاذ القانون والامن والقدره
الدفاعيه هذا الخطاب هو جزء لا يتجزا من
تركيز الصين المتزايد على الامن العالمي
والذي يبدو موجها الى حد كبير الى
الولايات المتحده فوا واشنطن راقبت
الاجتماع عن كثب ومخاوفها تتركز على ان
دول اسيا الوسطى تبحث عن شريك امنيا
موثوقا به في غياب روسيا وفي نفس الوقت لا
تبحث عن شريك ضد روسيا ما يعني ان
الولايات المتحده ليست خيارا فما تريده
الحكومات الاقليميه في اسيا الوسطى كما
تقول فورن بوليسي ليس الحمايه ضد القوه بل
ضمانا امنيا ضد التمردات المحليه روسيا
كانت لعبت هذا الدور سابقا وارسلت الاف
الجنود الى كازاخستان للمساعده في اخماد
انتفاضه مناهضه للحكومه لكن تورطها في
الحرب الاوكرانيه افصح المجال امام الصين
لتكون البديل لكن هذا لا يعني ان يتم فصل
روسيا عن اسيا الوسطى او العكس فطالما ان
موسكو وبيكين تعتبران واشنطن عدوا لهما
فان التنافس السلمي نسبيا على النفوذ
سيبقى مقبولا
[موسيقى]
ومن التمدد الصيني في اسيا الوسطى الى
التنافس بين بكين وواشنطن للسيطره على
مستقبل افريقيا الاخضر فالقاره السمراء
موطن العديد من المواد الخام في سباق
الحياد الكربوني ففي سعيهما نحو ازاله
مخاطر الكربون تحتاج الولايات المتحده
واوروبا لافريقيا للوصول الى هذه الغايه
لكن عقبه الصين تواجه تلك المساعي الغربيه
في افريقيا وتعيقها فبعد عقود من
الدبلوماسيه الصينيه الناجحه ومساعدات
التنميه في هذه القاره يحتاج الغرب الى
اعاده بناء الشراكات هناك وفقا لمبادئ
المعامله بالمثل فمليارات الصين المستثمره
لقد صدى لدى الدول الافريقيه التي غالبا
ما تتهم الغرب بالنفاق فيما يتعلق بمساله
الطاقه وتحول نحو النظيفه منها خاصه بعد
ازمه الغاز الروسي اما بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده فحققت تقدما افضل من اوروبا
التزمت باستثماراتها للحفاظ على الامن
الغذائي والبنيه التحتيه للطاقه المتجدده
في افريقيا يقدر الخبراء ان الصين استثمرت
بالفعل ما مجموعه 120 مليار دولار في
افريقيا بين عامي 2007 وعشرين عشرين في
حين استثمرت الولايات المتحده 20 مليار
دولار فقط خلال نفس الفتره احد ابرز اوجه
السباق بين واشنطن وبكين في افريقيا
بالذات هو الوصول الى المواد الخام
الحاسمه في صناعه عده مثل البطاريات
والالواح الشمسيه وتمثل البلدان الافريقيه
بالفعل اكثر من خمس انتاج الليثيوم وثلثي
الانتاج العالمي من الكوبالت والبوكسايت
والبلاتين والعديد من المواد الاخرى تسيطر
الصين على سلسله توريد باكملها في افريقيا
تقريبا من الاستخراج وشحن الى التقرير
والمعالجه ويتعين على صناع السياسات في
اوروبا والولايات المتحده ان يبداوا في
الاستماع الى ما يطلبه نظرائهم الافارقه
هذا يعني مزيد من الاستثمارات كما تقول
[موسيقى]
طبعا المنافسه على افريقيا لا يمكن ان تظل
موسكو خارجها ايضا فتعميقه العلاقات في
القارات السمراء اصبح اولويه ملحه بالنسبه
لكريملين ولكن نظرا لانها لا تستطيع
التنافس في التجاره والاستثمار فان
تكتيكاتها تهدف في المقام الاول الى تقويض
وتعطيل نفوذ الغرب وتوقيع صفقات اسلحه
كينيا التي تعتبر اكثر المنتقدين الافارقه
للحرب في اوكرانيا وصوتت في الامم المتحده
لادانه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه استقبلت
لافروف في زياره مفاجئه موسكو لديها
طموحات لقاعده بحريه في المنطقه مع الوصول
الى قناه السويس والمحيط الهندي ما يجعل
التقارب مع كينيا ضروره رئيس بوتين يستعد
لاستضافه القاده الافارقه في وقت لاحقا من
هذه السنه وهي القمه الثانيه منذ عام 2019
والتي اشتذبت 43 رئيس دوله الى سوتشي
نذهب الان الى لندن ومعنى دكتور مصطفى
بازركان الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي دكتور
مصطفى اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء
اذا ما تحدثت عن اعين الصين الى افريقيا
هذه المره هل المساله جيوسياسيه بحته ام
ان افريقيا هي المنازل وفير الاقتصادي
بالنسبه للصين فعلا
بالتاكيد هي ليست سياسيه فقط ولكن
اقتصاديه
بحث ايضا لماذا لانه الصين تمكنت من
الاستثمار في افريقيا وسبقت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قد يتفاجا المشاهد
الكريم انه في العام 2008 كان هناك
استثمارات امريكيه بحدود الثمانين مليار
دولار في افريقيا ولكنها تراجعت وبلغت كما
ذكرته في التقرير الى عشرين مليار لماذا
لانه الولايات المتحده كانت تعتمد على
النفط من اكبر اربع دول افريقيه لتزويدها
ولكن بسبب النفط والغاز الصخري الذي اكتشف
في الولايات المتحده تراجع هذا الاهتمام
وتراجعت
يعني واردات امريكا من افريقيا ولذلك
استغلت الفرصه من الصين الصين دخلت بشكل
واسع جدا ليس بالاستثمارات اقامه
المستشفيات اقامه المدارس قامت المصانع
كسبت
شعب الدول الافريقيه
دوله وهذه نقطه مهمه تمثل 20% من سكان
العالم لديها لديها مناجم للمعادن تمثل
30% من المعادن العالم من ضمنها كما ذكرتم
في التقرير والنيجر المهم جدا
فكيف ذلك من افريقيا على الصين فيما يتعلق
بحرب التجاريه بينها وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وايضا الحروب
الجيوسياسيه في المنطقه
اعتقد افريقيا الانواع وستستغل هذا
التنافس الامريكي الصيني ولذلك كان هناك
العامل الماضي القمه الافريقيه الصينيه
الرئيس بايدن وعد افريقيا بضخ استثماراتها
وكان هناك توقيع لاتفاق تجاري سينتهي
العمل به في العام 2025 هذا يحتاج الى
تنفيذ لماذا لان هناك اتفاق تجاري بعدم
شمول اكثر من 6,800
بضائع من افريقيا الى الولايات المتحده
اليوم لا لا يشمل هذا الا الف سلعه هذا
هذه الدلعة لانه لابد من تنافس والصين هي
لها الباع الاعمق والاكثر في افريقيا
هذا التنافس يعني في محاولات
امريكيه وحتى روسيه لسحب البساط من النفوذ
الصيني في افريقيا فهل تنجح هذه المحاولات
ام ان الغلبه دائما اقتصاديه للصين في
افريقيا
دعيني اوضح نقطه انه ما قبل حرب اوكرانيا
يختلف ما بعد حرب اوكرانيا وحتى في
افريقيا لماذا لانه ظهر هناك عدو مشترك
وهو بين الصين وروسيا الصين هي المستفيد
الاكبر من الحرف في اوكرانيا على مصادر
الطاقه تمكنت من الحصول على غاز ونفط مخفض
جعلها
دولار في افريقيا هذا يجعل بالاضافه الى
حاجه افريقيا لهذه الاستثمارات قد يتفاجا
لمشاهد الكريم افريقيا لديها امكانيه لجذب
استثمارات تصل الى 5.6 تريليون دولار خلال
الخمس سنوات الخمسه القادمه ولذلك انا
اعتقد هذا التناسب التنافس سيستمر وسيشتد
خلال السنوات القادمه
طيب دكتور مصطفى يعني اليوم خلاصه الحديث
هل تنجح الصين في توسيع نفوذها افريقيا في
ضوء الحرب البارده الجديده انصح تسميتها
مع الغرب
اعتقد انه ستنجح لماذا لانه هناك توقعات
بانه ستتبول المركز الاول في الاقتصاد
العالمي خلال السنوات الخمسه القادمه هذه
النقطه النقطه الثانيه حينما يكون هناك
دخول مبكر للصين في الاستثمارات هناك ايضا
لا ننسى كما ذكرتم مسائل البيئه وخفض
اطلاقات الكربون الصين هي
اليوم هي اصبحت المصدر الاول للسيارات
الكهربائيه في العالم والسيارات المعتاده
في شهر ابرير الماضي ولديها سيطره على
كافه سلسله الامداد لصناعه السيارات من
المعادن الى صناعه السيارات والبطاريات
هذا يجعل رغم انها هي هي الخارج الاكبر عن
التوحد ضده مصادر الطاقه ولذلك تعتمد على
النفط اكثر من اي دوله في العالم شكرا
جزيلا لكم دكتور مصطفى الباحث في الاقتصاد
السياسي
[موسيقى]
الصين تاخرت وتحاول اللحاق بالركب فصولات
وحليفها روسي وجولاته الامريكيين في عالم
الفضاء تكملها بكثير بكين ارسلت ثلاثه
رواه فضاء من بينهم مدني للمره الاولى في
تاريخها باتجاه محطه
الصينيه الفضائيه الخاصه بها وبمهمه وصفت
بالتجربه الثمينه لهذا العملاق الاسيوي
هي محطه الفضاء المعياريه الكبيره الصينيه
هي محطه فضاء تدور في مدار ارضي منخفض بين
كيلومترا
و540 كيلومترا فوق السطح تعد جزءا من
الخطوه الثالثه لبرنامج الفضاء الصيني
الماهول وستكون محطه بعد اكتمالها في خمس
حجم محطه الفضاء الدوليه وبنفس حجم محطه
تطمير الروسيه المحطه الصينيه معياريه من
الجيل الثالث كالمحطتين اللتين سبق ذكرهما
اي انه جرى تجميعها في المدار من اجزاء
اطلقت بشكل منفصل تساهم اساليب التصميم
المعياريه بتحسين الموثوقيه بشكل كبير
وايضا خافض التكاليف وتقصير دوره التطوير
وتلبيه متطلبات مهام متنوعه يجري يتحكم
بالمحطه من مركز بكين الجوف فضائي التحكم
والسيطره وتهدف الى توفير فرص للتجارب
الفضائيه وحتى بناء القدره على الابتكار
العلمي والتكنولوجي شمل التصميم الاولي
للمحطه لثلاث وحدات حتى نهايه العام
الماضي مع امكانيه اضافه ست وحدات مستقبلا
ويفترض ان تبقى في المدار لعشر سنوات على
الاقل كانت انطلقت الوحده الرئيسيه في
محطه
او تناغم السماوات كانت انطلقت في التاسع
والعشرين من ابريل 2021 توفر هذه الوحده
اي مقصوره دعما واماكن المعيشيه لثلاثه
رواد فضاء تشمل ادوات التوجيه بلاحه تحكم
بالمحطه وتوفر ايضا انظمه الطاقه تتكون
الوحده من ثلاثه اقسام اماكن المعيشه قسم
الخدمه وايضا نقطه الالتحام
[موسيقى]
انفصلت المركبه دراغون التي تحمل على
متنهار ايدي الفضاء ريان برناوي وعلي
القرني انفصلت عن محطه الفضاء الدوليه
وبدات رحله عوده ريان وعلي الى الارض في
رحله قد تمتد الى ثلاثين ساعه تبدا
بالانفصال ومن ثم دخول الغلاف الجوي قبل
ان تهبط في وجهتها النهائيه على الارض
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمر هو نتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
الليره تعكر صفوار بعد نشوه النصر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بلاد التاسعه هذا المساء مستمرون
معكم وفي جديد الاخبار اختبار حاسم تواجهه
صفقه رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس مجلس
النواب كبن مقارتي المتعلقه بسقف الديون
مكان الاختبار قاعه مجلس النواب اما الهدف
فتمرير مشروع القانون والحصول على دعم
كافر من الحزبين لتعليق حد الدين قبل
الموعد النهائي اي في الخامس من يونيو
فاليوم يحضر التشريع امام لجنه قوانين
مجلس النواب التي تتكون من تسعه جمهوريين
واربعه ديمقراطيين عضوان جمهوريان منهم
بالفعل عارضا الصفقه بحسب
ورغم ذلك فان الرئيس الامريكي مرتاح بل
اكد انه يشعر بشعور جيد حيال ذلك لافتا
الى عدم وجود سبب لعدم التمرير في الوقت
المناسب لتجنب التخلف عن السداد في كلا
المجلسين يمكن لمعارضي مشروع القانون
ابطاء تمريره فالمحافظون يعارضون الصفقه
لانها لا تذهب بعيدا بما يكفي للحد من
الانفاق الفيدرالي بينما يصف تقديمويون
قيود الانفاق بالشديده للغايه وفي حال
الموافقه على مشروع القانون المقترح في
مجلس النواب فسيواجه جدولا زمنيا مضغوطا
في مجلس الشيوخ حيث قد يستغرق تمريره
اياما مع وجود مطالبات بتعديل بعض بنوده
[موسيقى]
اذا صفقت وسفقه سقف الديون التي يروج لها
بايضا ومكارسي قد تواجه حقل الغام الجمهور
وديمقراطي يهدد مصيرها على ماذا تنطوي اذا
تعليق الالتزام بسقف الدين البالغ حاليا
واحدا وثلاثين تريليون و400 مليار دولار
حتى يناير 2025 اي ما يتيح للحكومه
الامريكيه سدد التزاماتها في المقابل يتم
الابقاء على الحد الاقصى للانفاق التقديري
غير الدفاعي عند مستويات العام الحالي اي
936 مليار دولار في عام 2024
وزيادته بواحد في المئه فقط في العام الذي
يليه فيما يرفع الانفاق الدفاعي الى نحو
886 مليار دولار اي زياده بواقع 11% عن
المبلغ المخصص في الميزانيه الحاليه اتفاق
حد الديون يشمل نقل التمويل الخاص لدائره
الايرادات الداخليه ومن شان قطع ما قيمته
مليارا من اصل 80 مليار دولار مخصصه
لتعزيز انفاذ الضرائب وايضا تحديث
تقنياتها خلال 10 سنوات وفق نيويورك تايمز
في الاتفاق ايضا استعاده نحو 30 مليار
دولار من الاموال غير المستخدمه والتي
كانت مخصصه لكورونا وتتراوح قيمتها
الاصليه بين 50 و 70 مليار دولار فبعيدا
ومكار في اتفقا على قواعد جديده لتسريع
المراجعات تسهيل التصاريح لمشاريع الطاقه
وهي اولويه جمهوريه في محاوله لجعل
التغيير اكثر قبولا للديمقراطيين من
المتوقع ان تلغي الصفقه متطلبات العمل
المحاربين القدامى وحتى المشردين
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى واشنطن ومعنا حسين الطول مراسل
العربيه حسين اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا
المساء لجنه القواعد بمجلس النواب كخطوه
اولى ماذا نتوقع اليوم
تحيه لك نادين نستطيع ان نقول بان اليمين
الجمهوري غير راض واليسار الديمقراطي غير
سعيد بهذه الصفقه لذلك التصويت اليوم هو
الاختبار الاول لها في لجنه القواعد في
مجلس النواب من المرجح ان يمر هذا اليوم
هذا الاتفاق يتم التصويت عليها رغم معارضه
عدد من الجمهوريين
والتخوف من مشاركتهم من قبل اربع نواب
ديمقراطيين في اللجنه ولكن هناك من يقول
بان الديمقراطيين لن يتخلوا عن رئيسهم في
هذه في هذا الموضوع وسيصوتون لصالح تمرير
هذا الاتفاق لياتي غدا الى قاعه مجلس
النواب ليكون هناك تصويت عليه يوم غد حسين
كيف يتم التعامل مع القلق من قبل بعض
الجمهوريين وبعض الديمقراطيين اذا الوصول
الى التسويه ما
قاده الكونغرس ان كنا نتحدث عن مجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
يحفزون المشرعين السيناتورز والنواب على
التصويت لصالح هذا
الاتفاق وهذا التشريع الجميع كل طرف من
الطرفين ديمقراطي وجمهوري يحاول ان يظهر
بانه لم يقدم الكثير من التنازلات وانه
بالعكس حصل على تنازلات من الطرف الاخر
ولكن بالنسبه للتقدميين الديمقراطيين
وبالنسبه لليمين للجمهوري يرى بان كل من
الرئيس بايدن وكبن مكارتي قدموا تنازلات
كثيره وقدموا تنازلات الى درجه ان
الاصلاحات التي تحدث عنها الجمهوريون
يرونها بانها غير كافيه لاصلاحات في
الانفاق كما ادنى الديمقراطيين يرون بان
الرئيس بايدن قدمت على مستوى البرامج
الاجتماعيه مثل برامج الحصول على
المساعدات الحكوميه بان يعمل من يطلب هذه
المساعدات يعمل اكثر من المكان يعمل عليه
سابقا اذا ليس هناك رضا كامل عن هذا
الموضوع ولكن ق الحزبين يعملان ويسعون الى
دفع هؤلاء المشرعين الى التصويت لتمريره
غدا في مجلس النواب وجمعه او خلال العطله
النهايه الاسبوع القادمه في مجلس الشيوخ
ايضا يواجه معارضه جمهوريه وهو نائب زينه
الجمهوري تعهد بانه سيصوت ضده بانه سيقدم
اقتراح اخر بديلا عام هذا الكلام حسين من
يعرقل ومن يريد عرقله صراحه وعلانيه صفقه
بايدن مكارثي
بدرجه الاولى طبعا الجمهوريين من اليمين
المتطرف كنا نتحدث في مجلس النوابه ومجلس
الشيوخ كما كنت تحدث قبل قليل هناك
السيناتور الجمهوري راند بول الذي قال انه
سيصوت ضده واقترح بان يتم رفع سقف الدين ب
500 مليار دولار مبدئيا وبعد اشهر يتم
التفاوض من جديد على اصلاحات في الانفاق
ايضا كان
هناكلي وهو ادم محافظ الذي تعهد باستخدام
كل الاجراءات لديه من اجل تعطيل التصويت
على هذا المشروع حتى ايضا كان انتقد هذا
الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه بايدن ومكارتي
ولكن الاعتراض لا يقتصر فقط على الجمهورين
وان كانهم اكثر حده بل حتى التقدميين من
الديمقراطيين كما قلنا لديهم تحفظات
ولديهم مخاوف بشان تجديد شروط طلب
المساعدات الاجتماعيه التي اعتبروا ان
بايدن تنازل عنها وبانها ستضر بناخبيهم
لاسيما عندما نتحدث عن الولايات
الديمقراطيه مثل نيويورك التي تعطي
[موسيقى]
كما مساعدات غذائيه للفقراء الان هناك
تجديد لشروط الحصول على هذه المساعدات اذا
هذا
الاعتراض هو اعتراض من الحزبين في ظل
تاييد ايضا من الحزبين له لتجنب رفع سقف
الدين العقلاء اذا صح التعبير من الحزبين
يريدون ان يمضوا بهذا الاتفاق على الاقل
هذا الاسبوع لكي يتم تجنب ازمه عدم قدره
الولايات المتحده على تسديد ديونها لانه
في النهايه المطاف يقول الخبراء بان لا
احد في مجلس الشيوخ سيجروا مجلس النواب
يقف امام الامريكيين ويقول لهم انا تسببت
بهذه الازمه لانه كان يريد ان يحصل على
مزيد من التنازلات من الطرف الاخر شكرا
جزيلا لك من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
مبيت تركي على رئيس نفسه لم يكن كاستقادها
سقوط مدون العمله المحليه التي قدمت اسوا
اداء يومي لها في ثمانيه اشهر حيث استفاق
الشعب التركي على التداعيات فوريه لفوز
اردوغان تمثلت بهبوط الليره التركيه
لمستوى قياس جديد عند 20.2 مقابل الدولار
تراجعت بنسبه 0.5% عن مستوى الاغلاق الذي
سجلته امس ليصبح ازمه اجمالي خساره قيمتها
7.3% منذ بدايه العام الليره التركيه فقدت
اكثر من 90% من قيمتها خلال السنوات
العشره الماضيه اثر مرور الاقتصاد بدورات
من الازدهار كساد ونوبات من التضخم
المستفحل اقتصاديون سبعه وامكانيه استمرار
سياسات اردوغان متمثله بخفض اسعار الفائده
والتدابير الطارئه لدعم العمله مع انخفاض
احتياطات العمله التركيه بسرعه انخفضت
احتياطيات تركيا بنحو 27 ملي هذا العام مع
محاولات الدوله دعم الليره وتمويل عجز
الحساب الجاري عند مستويات قياسيه قريبه
قدرت هذه الاحتياطات بما في ذلك العملات
الاجنبيه والذهب باعلى بقليل من مئه مليار
دولار بحسب بيانات رسميه في مصافي
الاحتياطيات وهو رقم سبعه التزامات فيبلغ
بالواقع صفر هو سلبي للغايه عند استبعاد
عشرات المليارات من الدولارات من الاموال
المقترضه من النظام المصرفي المحلي
لا تزال اصداء فوز اردوغان تهيمن على
الاجواء في تركيا لكن الرئيس الذي اعيد
انتخابه سيصدم سريعا بوضع اقتصادي حرج قد
يتطلب اجراءات اليمه خاصه وان اردوجان قطع
وعودا بمليارات الدولارات خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه وضخ عشرات المليارات الاخرى
لتعويم الليره التركيه قبل الاقتراع
انتهت علينا الان ان نسخر طاقاتنا للانتاج
وخدمه الشعب والتخفيف من اثار الزلزال
وهذا سيكون اولويتنا سنهتم بالمناطق
المنكوبه وسنحد من تاثيرات التضخم
الاقتصادي على البلاد ولن يكون ذلك صعبا
علينا
[موسيقى]
شركه كابيتال ايكونوميكس قالت ان ساعه
الحقيقه قد تقترب للاقتصاد التركي فبعد ان
كان مدعوما بيد عامله رخيصه ونظام مصرفي
فعال غدا يعاني مشكله تسببت بها السلطه
التنفيذيه نفسها خلال خوض المعركه
الانتخابيه اتخذ اردوغان اجراءات ابرزها
حربه ضد نسب الفوائد المرتفعه كما قام
بتغيير حكام البنك المركزي النتائج كانت
كارثيه اذ هبطت الليره التركيه وتجاوز
التضخم السنوي الرسمي نسبه
85% في الخريف المشكله الاكثر الحاحا
بالنسبه لتركيا الان هي ان مصرفها المركزي
تنقصه السيوله فقد انفق البنك المركزي
حوالي 30 مليار دولار لدعم الليره منذ
ديسمبر ما دفع احتياطياه من النقد الاجنبي
الى المنطقه السلبيه للمره الاولى منذ
وغادر معظم المستثمرين الاجانب خوفا من
عدم الاستقرار فيما قدر خبراء ان حيازه
السندات التركيه من قبل حامل السندات
الاجانب انخفضت بحوالي 85 بالمئه مقارنه
مع 2013
ويرى المحللون ان الحكومه التركيه لن يكون
امامها من خيار اخر سوى رفع اسعار الفائده
تحضيرات اطلقها خبير في الذكاء الصناعي من
ان الملايين من العاملين في مجال الوجبات
السريعه سيفقدون وظائفهم في فتره تتراوح
بين خمس الى عشر سنوات وذلك بعد ان تحل
محلهم روبوتات وانظمه ذكاء الصناعي
موظف قطاع مطاعم الوجبات السريعه في مرمى
الذكاء الاصطناعي والمهله امامهم ما بين
الخمس والعشر سنوات بعدها قد ينتهي الوجود
البشري في هذا المجال وتحل محله روبوتات
وانظمه اتمته كامله بدءا من اخذ الطلبات
مرورا باعداد الطعام وانتهاء بتقديمه تطور
يوصف بالثوري فللمره الاولى سينتقل الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليشغل وظائف يتعامل فيها بشكل
مباشر مع البشر مؤسس شركه فالينت المتخصصه
في الذكاء الاصطناعي روبكار بينتر قال
اننا سنرى الذكاء الاصطناعي يقفز من
المكاتب الخلفيه الى الوظائف في الواجهات
الاماميه والتي كانت حكرا على البشر
كاربنتر ضرب مثلا بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
المعروفه باسم هولي والتي اثبتت قدرات على
عمليه البيع تفوق قدرات البشر كما اعتبر
كاربنتر ان محركه ليمتلك القدره في التفوق
على البشر في حال استلامه اكثر من طلب
التحذيرات من ان يحل الذكاء الاصطناعي محل
البشر ليست الاولى اذ نشرت مؤسسه جولد مان
ساكس في مارس الماضي تقريرا يوضح ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يستحوذ على نحو
300 مليون وظيفه من البشر وبدوام كامل وهو
ما قد يجعل البشر امام مستقبل غامض مع
منافسهما الذكي ولو اصطناعيا
[موسيقى]
في مجرات لتقنيات الذكيه التي تجتاح عالم
الاتصالات طرح تطبيق واتساب تحديثا يمكن
المستخدم من مشاركه ما يعرض على شاشته مع
هاتف اخر واتساب طرح التحديث على بعض
الهواتف التي تعمل بنظام اندرويد بشكل
تجريبي لكن يتوقع ان يعمم تحديث على
الهواتف التي تعمل بهذا النظام قريبا
ويظهر تحديث ويظهر على شكل ايقونه هاتف مع
سهم عند النقر فوق الزر الجديد تظهر رساله
تسال المستخدم عما اذا كانوا يريد بدء
تسجيل ما يجري على الشاشه او الارسال الى
الهاتف الاخر
في نهايه التاسع هذا المساء لم يبقى الا
ان نذكر بالعناوين
بعد كيف مسيرات تضرب موسكو للمره الثانيه
وتكسر حصنتها بوتين يتوعد و واشنطن في اي
دور لها
الغول الحرب ضدك
ردا على اتهامات دعم السريع البرهان ينفي
اي صله للاخواني بالحرب ويهددهم باستخدام
القوه المميته
صراع محترف بين بكين و واشنطن لخطب
افريقيا والعروس السمراء تستعرض ثرواتها
صفقه باي مكارسي حول سقف الدين تواجه
اختبارا عصيرا في غرفتي الكونجرس بعد
ساعات من الان
التاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبرنا
بالتاكيد مستمره بعد قليل طاهر بركه 360
ساعه اخباريه مختلفه معك يا طاهر شكرا لك
يا نادين طبعا سنتابع اخر المعطيات في
بيلجورود على الارض بعد استهدافها
اوكرانيا استهداف روسيا بالمسيرات كما كان
لديك ايضا ونسال لماذا ليس تصميم في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه كوني معا تابع طيبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات